i'd like to share some benefits of
coffee that you may have never heard
about now coffee is the most addictive
substance on the planet and with over 2
billion cups of coffees served today and
that was actually 2016
there's a lot of people who drink coffee
and i'm definitely not about promoting
any addicting substances but if you can
keep
your coffee at a small amount okay there
are some really interesting benefits now
i personally only drink one cup of
coffee every single day i don't put
sugar in it and i make sure it's organic
because coffee is one of the most
chemically treated crops of all crops in
just one acre of coffee some farmers use
up to 250 pounds of chemicals not to
mention when you use herbicides like
roundup ready glyphosate that actually
destroys the soil as well so if you're
going to drink coffee definitely do
organic and don't do too much because
the side effects of coffee
are definitely
negative effects on your sleep
negative effects on your cholesterol and
too much coffee can definitely affect
the cardiac rhythm and give you
arrhythmias but i think most people know
coffee improves your cognitive function
it can improve your physical performance
it can positively affect your mood but
there are eight
additional benefits that i want to share
with you that you may have never heard
before now i've extracted a lot of this
information from
my new favorite research tool called
elicit.org i'll put a link down below if
you haven't heard about it it's a tool
to extract data from over two million
different
papers so number one coffee has the
ability to lower your risk from dementia
alzheimer's and parkinson's because of
what it can do
to your nervous system coffee helps
prevent oxidation
to the neurons and it does it through a
very special protective gene
called nrf2-are
so this is protection against the death
of the neuron from oxidative stress all
right number two coffee can lower the
risk against gallstones
because coffee has certain
phytonutrients that stimulate the
production of bile the flow of bile the
hormones that control the gallbladder
contraction and relaxation coffee can
help thin the bile which sometimes
becomes congested and can back up in the
bile ducts and cause all sorts of pain
in the gallbladder area in the liver
that can radiate to your right side but
remember if you're putting a bunch of
crap in your coffee like
sugar and syrup and things like that i'm
not talking about that coffee and the
reason i want to bring that up is
because when you're
consuming conventional coffee with all
the pesticides that can put a strain on
the gallbladder and your liver all right
number three
coffee has the ability to lower the risk
of getting kidney stones and there's
even some research that shows that it
can even help counter chronic kidney
disease all right number four coffee can
give you an anti-carcinogenic
effect so it's anti-cancer against the
prostate colorectal cancer
skin cancer as in melanoma as well as
liver cancer and number five coffee has
an anti-inflammatory effect so if you
have inflammation from arthritis
bursitis tendinitis any of the itis's
coffee can help all right number six
metabolic syndrome okay where a person
has insulin resistance or they have too
much insulin metabolic syndrome is a
combination of having high blood glucose
it's high blood pressure it's high
cholesterol and it's definitely
involving blood sugar issues and insulin
resistance all right number seven coffee
has the potential to decrease
risk of all-cause mortality coffee can
apparently help you live a little longer
and again all this research i'm going to
put down below you can check it out for
yourself and lastly number eight coffee
is hepatoprotective which means it
supports the liver as in decreasing the
risk of getting a fatty liver as in
decreasing the complications from
hepatitis b and hepatitis c as well as
the complications from liver
cirrhosis now a lot of people who are on
keto do the bulletproof coffee which is
totally fine you add a little mct oil
and butter and that will help you fast
longer both these fats added to coffee
can spike your ketones and give you more
cognitive benefits and if you haven't
seen my video on the bulletproof coffee
i put it right here check it out
you